jordan uh just bring people up to date
on what it is
you're doing so um for the last about
six years i've been traveling the world
and doing
uh speaking some you know i guess
motivational speaking is part of a lot
of it's more about
strategy for entrepreneurship sales
venture capital
uh things like that and now i'm in as
you said i'm embarking on a really
massive us tour about 50 or 60 cities
over the next
24 months and i'm giving all the profits
back to investors who lost money in 20
years ago
um so that's the story i'm really
excited about that because it's a lot of
work and it makes it
even that more exciting to do it so
kerry so
a lot of the discussion that we've been
having today is why
over the last several years there's been
no criminal prosecutions of the top ceos
on wall street that were really
held you know what people think are held
responsible
for the financial crisis now you went to
jail for financial crimes and obviously
paid the price for that
what's your take on that banks are
paying huge fines
multi-billion dollar fines on these
things but we're still not seeing uh
criminal prosecution so where do you see
that
i think that the problem is a lot of the
laws that were broken
are in the gray and difficult to prove
so what happened basically is there was
you know this incestuous relation
between the government and wall street
where people that were in wall street
went
to the public sector they changed the
rules and allowed these loopholes which
then people on wall street jumped
through
so while there was certainly some
illegal acts a lot of what happened was
really more about taking advantage of
loopholes
so it's in the gray you know there was
some crimes committed for sure but very
difficult to prove so i think
the government you know in rightfully so
has to sort of pick their spots and they
they don't want to fight losing cases um
and they're probably doing the best they
can could they do better yeah
um should some people go to jail i'm
sure but
um again a lot of those cases they're
very difficult to prove on a criminal
level and the burden of proof on a civil
case
is much easier so what you see is the
bias towards bringing these
civil cases with large fines versus
wasting resources on criminal cases
you mentioned going to jail you spent 22
months
in prison right for your actions you
have spoken about reform for yourself
i'm wondering if you can just give us
some thoughts as to what that was like
and
what did you decide was a good way to
reform yourself
my path was different than most because
what happened was
she saw the movie or read the book she
had this massive drug addiction and
i wouldn't say the drugs caused the
activities that happened on wall street
that was really the scent
slowly step by step fueled by greed and
so forth where i
started off doing things right and then
started breaking the law with stock
manipulation
when i got sober i looked back and was
kind of freaked out at some of the
things i'd done because now i started
getting perspective
and then i got invited a year later um
when i went to jail
that was certainly you know a point
where you get to examine your past but
then i started writing a book
and when you write it's almost like this
advanced form of hypertherapy where you
get to
re-examine your actions from above and
you peel back the layers and look at
your motivations and
what was driving you and the good the
bad the ugly the insecurities and i was
able to get a wholly
different perspective on myself and i
when i
left jail emerged from jail and was
right and finishing writing this book
uh you know i was already the point
where i knew i would never ever do
anything again that was even in the gray
that was
i knew in my heart i was raised by a
great family uh i didn't go out into the
world to commit any crimes or fraud it
was sort of
a kind of a left turn in albuquerque so
it was easy for me to come back to the
person that i originally was
was there a tipping point because as you
said you didn't start out
wanting to commit fraud but then was
there a point that
you can recall that was that left turn
to albuquerque
there was it started with one gigantic
rationalization that it was okay to take
a bag of cash for someone to hide a
trade that didn't make sense on paper
and they were saying oh everyone on wall
street does it was an older person who
was around for many years
and i think you know in my heart it's
many years like 28 years ago i knew
it was wrong and i shouldn't have done
it but i said you know what i'll never
do it again
but once you take that first step over
the ethical line what happens is your
ethical line moves
and then you're doing things right again
but next time you step over you step a
bit further still because you've become
desensitized the next time further still
further stone before you know it through
these
tiny almost imperceptible steps you're
doing things you thought you'd never do
you're a socio people you never thought
you'd associate with and it all seems
okay so that was
that first point and then there was a
point where i was like i realized that
things had spiraled so far out of
control
and at that point almost it got away
from me the firm was massive it was
thousands of people
i was you know the movie's fictionalized
i left the firm in 90
the end of 93 and i lost control of it
and um doesn't mean i'm not responsible
i'm the first person to take
responsibility but
you get in this and you get so deep in
something sometimes that
the abnormal seems normal and the normal
seems like a distant memory that's
really what happened